the team of Czech police officers
carries out controls on the Slovak
border they're looking for people they
say are illegal immigrants many of these
people are from Syria and are seeking
Refuge but not here they want asylum in
the UK or Germany and are willing to
cross many European borders to do so in
Berlin ministers say something must be
done
we will extend the checks on our borders
with Austria Beyond November for another
six months these checks are necessary to
prevent illegal immigration on the
border with a Czech Republic the federal
police have significantly increased
checks as part of stop and search
practices but intensifying border
controls may be more difficult than it
sounds because Germany and the Czech
Republic share a common Frontier of many
hundreds of kilometers and the Schengen
Zone rules still apply which means that
right now pretty much anybody can come
and go across this Frontier as they
please
so far this year the vast majority of
new immigrants in Germany have been
Ukrainian taking advantage of the
eu-wide freedom of movement their
country's citizens have people like
Natalia
um
my mother has cancer right after she
came to Germany she went for several
treatment sessions and got what she
needed
special reception centers for Ukrainian
refugees have been set up in several
German cities to cope with demand but
one complicating Factor right now is a
recent spike in arrivals of people from
Syria and Afghanistan whose Asylum
process is not as easy and yet who must
also be looked after we're running out
of capacities houses where people can
sleep and my date office is responsible
at the moment for 27 000 people live in
more than 90 houses all over Berlin with
the incoming people new arrivals we are
close to zero when it comes to proper
housing to hear officials speak like
that reminds some Germans of 2015 when
more than a million syrians came to this
country after Angelo Merkel opened the
borders to them today's politicians say
they have learned from the errors of the
past and are making more Provisions for
people who come now and yet at the same
time they're calling for borders to be
more tightly controlled to prevent
unauthorized entry Dominic Kane Al
Jazeera on the German Czech border